in education today there are a number of
directions that schools have taken over
the last century really the 20th century
across the country in almost every
school you see its college and career
readiness
so the prevailing view of what a human
being is is some kind of economic
producer education has moved in about
the same way everything public has moved
frankly ana.k 2 6 3 and everything you
do is micro managed by a district a
state legislature a Department of
Education now we live in an evolutionary
age where you think that everything is
changing and that keeping up with the
change or better helping to make the
change is the great goal
[Music]
we see the effects of that today where
schools don't have the same kind of
focus on content and so they have a
deficit of cultural literacy they have a
deficit of knowledge about the human
world in the natural world we have
students who come in here and they say
have to turn in homework I have homework
what's a zero you know at the college
level we had students entering with a
standard high school diploma who still
couldn't multiply and divide if it
wasn't a five paragraph essay and even
that was was a challenge so the skills
of a students were graduating with after
13 years of public education were pretty
mediocre I think there's a prevailing
sense that students are graduating
either morally lost or just adrift in
general or unclear on what life is for
the founders knew that an educated
citizenry was necessary to the health of
the Republic so the impacts of this can
be seen from the individual lives all
the way out to our nation today one side
really started doing my research on
classical head I kind of realized that
this was the missing piece this is what
they weren't getting and this is what
raises good strong college students and
eventually good strong adults
Barney charter school initiative is an
outreach of Hillsdale College and it's
an excellent way to reintroduce sound
learning classical liberal arts based
education
was common even ubiquitous in this
country we serve as the architect of the
academic program we're an advisor to
these schools so that they can continue
for many years to serve the families in
the communities and offer this kind of
excellent education here until still we
don't take any money from the government
so we don't take any money from these
schools but we offer them help
we've contrived a curriculum for and
with them and we help train their
teachers and we try to be of assistance
any way we can I will tell you the
school board about fell out of their
chairs when I described the relationship
with Hillsdale College in our Turner
school interview they have a whole team
of people who work to refine the
curriculum improve what kids are being
exposed to and they make some great
recommendations that really help shape
our program to be successful I think
last summer there were 400 or so
teachers here for a week to ten days
working with our faculty and with each
other the ability to pick up the phone
and call any member of the Barney
charter school initiative at any time
and say we have a problem and I don't
know how to fix it give me some guidance
and that's there they send a whole team
of teachers to starting schools give a
rundown on the
classroom management policies on just
the general tenor and culture that the
school should should be seeking they
came down and spent two weeks 80 hours
with our teachers training them on how
to do our curriculum and didn't ask for
anything in return
it's pretty amazing relationship I would
say in the classroom where the mission
is actually being fulfilled it's an
interaction between teacher and student
and curriculum
[Music]
we're much more focused on the
individual student and making them a
well-rounded human being it's not just
about their ability to pass a reading
test or a math test or to just be able
to read well which in many schools is
all that matters we teach the young
people to understand what a human being
is through the fabric of the curriculum
itself in the study of great figures in
history both those that exemplify virtue
and those that demonstrate Vice it's
their ability to understand the world
around them to understand the people
around them to be able to hold a
conversation with an adult I mean it's
so much more exciting when you can tell
these kids we're going to learn this
because it's hard because it's gonna
teach you to think in a way you've never
fought before and you are going to grow
as a human being because of it so being
able to do that and know why it's being
done makes teaching in a classical
school just fantastic experience
what I love most of all is seeing my
girls loving learning enjoying what
they're learning coming home and talking
about what they're learning
my son Jaden the kindergarten he grabbed
a program and begin to do phonograms on
the bulletin at church and for him to
even be thinking about that aside from
doing his homework I mean that really
really blew my mind for a kindergartner
to be so interested in it like that it's
funny because all of my children after
they came here from the public school
they said we want to go back to the
public school and I said why what what
did you like better about it because
this is important to me didn't make us
do anything so right off the bat it was
really well that seals it to see my
daughter come home and just pick up
books and just lay on the sofa no TV she
just wants to read they're reciting
poems for fun with their friends I mean
it's been it's been really great to see
that kind of change in growth in them
since they've been at the school I think
that's part of being in a classical
school is just being in a entire Society
of people that love learning
highlight useful because your kids get
an education and like you need to learn
things so you can be smart when you grow
up and you will have trouble with hard
stuff
is there anything else you want to tell
all those people out there about
Savannah classical Academy is amazing
you're amazing
I am finally in the world of education
that I should be in and I wish that
there were more schools that were doing
this many hundreds of people I think
maybe even thousands of people are
essential to the work of the Barney
project and we can't do it without that
[Music]
as a parent I became involved in
starting a school like this because I
wanted something for my own children now
seeing the impact we've had I think this
is the type of program we need a
throughout our state through our nation
the impact of the schools on the
community is is palpable the districts
take notice policymakers take note and
what that means for a local community
can be extended into what that means for
the nation the Barney project is growing
and of course it takes enormous outside
support and we appeal for more
[Music]
everyone everyone has stake in this so
this can get huge
it can grow every
[Music]
it's a sign of hope for me because there
is a desire and a recognition that
education is vital that we need to do
something to improve it we need to do
something to restore it and thousands of
children attending excellent schools
having your character shaped has
exciting prospects for this country
you